The code to do this is almost identical to the code we've used in
our scatter plot.
First, we create an extent, but in this case we're using our nested object.
And in our accessor function, we have to first reach into the values attribute
of our object and then grab the attendance, which we then use in our D3 scale.
In this case, we're setting it up to be a square root scale with input domain
equal to the extent we just created, and range on the order of 0 to 12.
Now, both for the type of scale we use.
Whether it's the square root, logarithmic, linear, and
what output range we choose.
It often takes some experimentation and
playing around with values to find out what visually looks the best.
And now we can properly scale our attendance values,
returning them in our accessor function for
the radius, and reload our page to see what affect this has had.
Well, as you can see here,
the circles have shrunken back down to a manageable size.
And we can see that there's some variation in how big they are,
which corresponds to the attendance for each